here now with reaction chief strategist
4d make America great again coalition
dr. Sebastian Gorka and civil rights
attorney Darryl parks Darryl let's start
with you your thoughts without question
that I think people are missing the
message here this has always been about
racial inequality in the country and
drawing attention to the racial
inequalities that African Americans and
people of color face every day in
America this has never been about
disrespecting the flag answer we all
love America
it creates wonderful opportunities for
all of us to succeed now the message
though needs to be clear the people who
are crying out the president needs to
find a way to bring us together and so I
call upon the president to find ways to
bring us together in understand what
Darrell is that he bringing us together
saying don't disrespect the flag in the
anthem and though don't disrespect those
labrie the head and died under the flag
and respect the flag respect the anthem
respect your country respect the
military that's what he's saying
but Sharon let me say this to you but he
also hasn't say why are the people feel
in this way while they feeling
inequalities exist what can he is the
president do to address this that's the
question for the president dr. Kirk mr.
parks you say you love the flag you love
this nation well along the flag as well
the red of that flag the stripes in that
flag that's the same red as the blood of
Americans that fought and died for this
nation and we didn't look upon them
based upon their skin color the blood of
a black African American is the same
color as an Asian as a white skinned
American the people who fought on the
beaches of Normandy who fought in
Vietnam in Korea in Afghanistan and Iraq
it's a symbol of unity if you can't see
the flag in the anthem as symbols of
unity but political tools then perhaps
you should think again about which
country you're loyal to well here's the
problem I think that when people are
loyal to the flag launch of the atom but
people still see their justices in the
streets that still exists throughout
America so we have to address that yes
the law to the flag yes we show
allegiance but we also see what's
happening when police
and inequities that exist throughout the
country so those things have to be
addressed and should their address you
were talking on the Trayvon Martin
you were wrong and what the outcome
would be you were wrong in Ferguson
what's wrong and a lot of people are
wrong and a lot of people wrong in
Baltimore Cambridge police didn't act
stupidly did they dr. Gorka when you see
those caskets come home from the
battlefields with dead American soldiers
and Marines in them do we think about
that flag having a skin color do we
think about that flag belonging to a
political party is it the gops flags of
the Democrats flag does it belong to the
urban cities does it belong to the
derisively called flyover States no none
of those dead Americans are honored by
the flag in parties and ways they are
honored because the flag is a symbol of
our nation it's a symbol of our unity
and if you don't want to have a unitary
nation then you don't have a nation if
you don't respect the flag then you
don't respect the lives of the people
who died for that nation it's that
simple
Sharon if I may without question when we
see this flag this is also the same flag
that we see young after American boys
also laying in caskets so there's you
must have seen the caskets and the lives
of our people who have died for no
reason at all under the law under the
flesh questions that we have to have
Darryl well no but you just said that so
why aren't we respecting the flag if
dead African Americans if dead white
Americans if dead Asian Latin American
Americans are respected by that flag on
the casket why do you want to disrespect
the flag I think you missed the point
when after American boys are dying in
our streets and the people who kill them
are not being brought to justice
that's inequity that people draw
attention to what did Obama do with all
these deaths and shootings and that
record numbers nothing nothing
home city he mentioned that like three
times in his presidency but sure without
question we also waiting the President
Trump to go to jail to dad has American
Thank You boss